Chuyện trân trời chứ rù văn chàng của Ram đã trở thành thông dân giễn tập tác chiến khi hải quân nần đầu tổ chức sự kiện kiện nghiệp.
Ngày hải quân, tại bài biển xe của mua hàng.
Chuyện trình thể hiện năng lửa phối hợp đà miền của lực lượng hải quân hiện đại thông qua xe kết thật đồng bộ.
Dựa lực lượng mặt nước, dưới nước và chính không, chân một chứa bài tập được sản dựa công phu.
Xe kết mở đau bằng mang chong mừng của chực thang lửa hát, sau miên rời.
Tính đó là đổi hình tông chiến cùng đối những trực thang trời tác.
Chien thông, mấy bài dưới nưa và hong, thực hiện nhiều bài bài trình giễn.
Chúng khi chúng ta hải cạnh chính xác lên bằng gì đồng của tổ khu chục i Ns, im phần.
Lực lộ mặt hốt nếu bật năng lực đặc nghiệp, thông qua các bạn yảnh tình đầu và kỹ thuật luôn giây nhàng.
Chuyện ngừng máo gồm phóng tên lửa từ tổ chieến tổ ngầm cơ đồng.
Phong mới khăn chính ca từ tổ xanh bài và chính giễn tổng nhàng bằng phản lực nước.
Với tổng cậu mới chính tổ chieến, một tổ ngầm và bà mẹ mẹ mẹ tham gia.
Sự kiến thếp lại với nghĩ tức chuyển thống trên bờ,
và hình định sức mạnh trong ngày hải quần ở nộ.